well hello and welcome
thank you thank you mr lupe fiasco
for joining us today sir it's wonderful
to have you
i'm sure you are known to them uh
i will introduce lupe fiasco
chicago-born grammy award-winning rapper
producer entrepreneur and activist
his studio albums are food and liquor
from 2006
the first followed by the cool
lasers food and liquor 2 tetsuo and
youth
drogas light and most recently drogas
wave
since then he's also given us an ep
house
and he's been involved with
organizations
including mural in chicago and
one that he'll be speaking about today
the
society of spoken art so soon
i want to give a quick shout out to some
of lupe's collaborators who are going to
be
working with him and hopefully with me
as well
during this residency which will uh we
very much hope
bring lupe um in his own physical self
to our mit campus um
akane ujjima ian condrey fox harel
are on the call with us here part of the
conference
so we're looking forward to working
together and
also to connecting with others at
mit and to having an event
the code cipher that will involve the
community
so lupe let me start off by
asking some about what you've been up to
in these
uh quite unconventional and
um turbulent times of the pandemic
uh you have uh you have
dropped the house ep uh
which maybe has some stuff that you were
thinking about beforehand those
dinosaurs
didn't didn't didn't come out of nowhere
but uh but it also um
connects to and and deals with some of
the
themes crises situations that we're in
you've done a charity concert live
streaming that
from your home and you started a podcast
the lupe and roy show
will you tell us some about what the
pandemic's been
like for you and how working during the
time has been and what you've
what you've been able to accomplish what
connections you've been able to make
oh wow thank you uh doc i t just want to
do a microphone check
make sure folks can uh can hear me um
thank you for the opportunity big shout
out to the staff at
mit um as well as to all the folks
running this behind the scenes catherine
higgins
the other nick who's running the av and
all the other folks are
putting this together shout out to to
the other uh irs
dr fox um and there's also some social
it's that are
in the chat today so appreciate the
opportunity thank you really excited
about the residency and i
can't wait to uh start exploring ideas
and concepts and thoughts
um you know pandemic wise to turn it
towards that
first and foremost you know prayers um
and sympathies
go out to the families um and
condolences to the folks who've lost
people uh astronomical amount of uh
human loss and human suffering um during
his time
so definitely don't want to overstep
that um
and and really pay homage to that but
also pay homage to the
to the uh the uh frontline workers um
and the different folks who are taking
care
of uh the elderly and the different
peoples uh volunteering their services
and you know being on the front lines
helping fight fight back this pandemic
um so definitely want to give them the
the shine
um and with that said um
you know it's a constrained time you
know and one of the things that
you know we we up which we'll get into
and talk about salsa
uh is uh how do you operate in a
constraint
you know how do you look at something um
with certain limitations and certain
parameters and still execute
you know through that so you know
everything went digital
you know it was literally last last few
days
of uh uh freedom if you want to call
that before there were lockdowns and
people kind of got their senses together
and really understood what was about to
take place
um you know we're on a the uh
uh minutes days away from going to the
airport
you know and getting on the plane and
going doing touring and doing this had
then europe did a bunch of shows and
everything was canceled uh pushed well
into next year now
and so it became digital you know what
can you do digitally what can you do at
a distance
um not only for the sake of the health
of other folks
um but for the sake of maintaining your
own business you know your kind of
entrepreneurial
uh aspirations so it really became like
okay we got to hit social media heavy
how can we
you know manipulate this and insert
ourselves in a meaningful way in that
space so i started to do uh
uh basically daily chats basically
kind of public health letting people
know where their master's down at their
um and then just chatting with the fans
and that evolved into you know podcast
you know with a fellow it actually uh
royce
um you know he was was in talks with one
of my friends to do a podcast and royce
called me out
blue and i was like let's do one
together so you know you get the royce
the five nine show birth out of
you know the pandemic um same thing with
the house ep
uh just kind of languishing around that
the house
get a random tweet from somebody say hey
this is a nice beat you should rap on it
say you know what you're right
um and then that goes into getting a
relationship with the producer and
then that's building a ep together and
putting it out you know entitled that
house
you know to kind of reinforce this
concept of of staying at home
um but making do what you have you know
um in these rather constrained
times um and then in terms of just
streaming concerts and things like that
you know i had a few opportunities
fortunately
um at a space in my career where i do
have some legacy material i still got
some relevance and still got some
commercial appeal so
you know those folks are still willing
to kind of show up to their laptops
for a lupe fiasco concert so you know we
took advantage of that and i actually
think we got another one coming up
pretty soon as well
um we're supposed to be doing a food and
liquor tour now so i think we're gonna
do a
a digital uh version you know for the
fans until things kind of open back up
so that's great to hear about because uh
i and i know other people um want to
you know try to figure out um how to
carry on
you know our practices artistic
practices are
reaching out and connecting with people
socially
into this very strange time
and so it's good to share the things
that work in those regards
um but um this is also a chance to
talk about something which involved uh
among other things
uh it involves distance learning uh
which is what we're doing
at mit and so so first of all i don't
want to
say that sosa is a distance learning
organization because it's more than that
i know
um and maybe uh instead of saying
anything more
i'll ask you to just introduce the
organization in general tell us some
about it
um and then we can go into some of the
you know different aspects different
components of what it does
absolutely and just to kind of be
thorough and maybe start at the
beginning of the narrative
um you know i'm a rapper um
started rapping when i was maybe
maybe maybe 12 maybe 13 um
but professionally at 17 you know
like literally looking down the barrel
of a record deal um
creating a company um getting that deal
losing that deal getting another deal in
the whole
rig of a row of the recording artist
experience
and at the same time balancing you know
the commercial aspect but also with the
you know perfecting and building your
craft at the same time so
do interviews do concerts sign record
deals but then also
how do i maximize my art you know and
create spaces for me to progress through
my art
and the early part of my career was all
about this is kind of pre-record deal
uh pieces of my career was all about
honing the craft
you know um understanding what the craft
is and then building on it
and then commercializing it you know to
be blunt you know what's the best thing
that i can do
but the process was very authentic it
was very natural
studying other rappers you know you know
at that point rap
and even even to even today rap is very
much so in the wild
um and so you have to kind of find forms
to to to study it and understand it and
practice it
um salsa comes up as an idea
because in that process of you know
going into the commercial space
of entertainment uh it's a lot of lot of
wolves out there
a lot of a lot of bad things that go
down
some wonderful things as well but some
bad things um
that you know could be fixed if we had
you know this with this would happen if
we had that we would have a fighting
chance if
we had this and that if was always um a
collective
right um but a collective that had a
certain
cachet and a force to collective bargain
right to bargain collectively right and
have um
certain incentives but also be able to
de-incentivize certain things
in the face of this kind of industrial
you know onslaught
uh and there was a lot of different
layers to that and it was kind of like
man if we had a union i wouldn't even i
wouldn't have to worry about this
you know if we had such and such had a
union he wouldn't have to worry about
that
if she was if we had a union she
wouldn't be going crazy right now
thinking about this and thinking about
that
it just felt like a union or some type
of collective bargaining aspect would
solve a lot of issues
um and so the wheels get to turning
right and it becomes okay well what does
that look like
um and it's well it's business so why
not a business
and the business aspect of it was just
way too way too many moving parts
right um way too many different sales um
way too many different allegiances from
artists to certain business practices
and certain business people so that was
kind of
doa um the next one was okay well what
about
uh creative you know what if we have
this creative
community that is just all about
creativity
and the wall with that was you know the
bed being too soft on that one was
uh there's not enough uh objectivity
there's too much subjectivity
you know it's it's it's so uh
so kind of ambiguous that you'll never
find like central points it'll just be
based on
the whims if you like this or if you
like that and if you don't then you
don't if you do
but that could change the next day and
you can't really build what i felt was a
collective
off of something so soft so
what was left was the objectives
you know that the the thing that we
never really had in in rap
never really had in hip-hop um was
what about a a institution right what
about the academics
you know what does the academics of rap
look like
you know we know what the creative looks
like we know what the business looks
like
but what does the academics look like of
rap
um and so it just became this oh
that's that's that's the move let's see
if i hit any walls along the way
and i didn't and if anything i got
accepted into it was more doors it was
actually all doors you know like hey
yeah come in and we're working on this
and
you know there's what have you studied
modern poetics and have you looked into
rhetoric and have you looked into this
and have you looked at that
so anyway it became you know very
apparent that to build
the foundation to build on would be a
foundation of academics
right it would make everybody even so it
didn't matter how commercially
successful you were
it didn't matter how artistically gifted
you were
if you didn't have a grasp of the uh
academia
of our craft then you we were all on the
same page
right and it was like okay cool so now
we bring everybody down to
zero for the most part and then
everybody can start to build on the same
principles
right and and the same kind of i ideas
and concepts and things like that
now whether you agree with them right
whether you choose to practice something
or not
um they're still objectively proven you
know it's kind of
data-driven fact-driven um and even if
it's a theory it's a theory that's been
well kind of
talked about and thrown around so
that became the job it became like okay
let's compile
as much of the back end the academics
the the the the math and the science and
the language and the language theory
and the cognitive theory and everything
that goes into speaking
you know an art a spoken art form um and
that's and you get the society of spoken
art
you know from that um which is a guilt
now go ahead i'm sorry i want to
highlight these two things that i think
are really fascinating one that sosa
as a uh organization is this process of
working through like the different
things it could be
could it be a union could it be a
company could it be creativity but
you know and uh and through thinking
that through that and trying out these
different ideas talking about them
like you you reach something so it's not
that um
uh you come up with the idea in its
perfect form and then you realize it but
but you work through that and you
develop to to what it is
uh that works out for you um and the
other thing that is
uh from my perspective uh i i'm glad
about it very much
for sosa but very funny is the idea that
sort of that academic perspective is one
that
leads toward equality and sort of gets
you away from hierarchies and things
like this right
because we're you know look at us um we
are
so uh hierarchical that you have to do
your bachelor's degree master's degree
phd you do post-doc
you get to be a junior faculty member
you know you get tenure
uh it's all of this this um
uh that um it has a lot of uh
hierarchy built in here and so i'm
always looking for
opportunities ways to work collectively
as you say
that can mix in to you know what
what for us has a lot of hierarchy and
structure
um but it's so it's good it's good to
hear how
um that concept is different in the
context of so-so but i would be
betraying
honesty if i did not you know uh
talk about the structure of so-so right
which kind of
is hierarchical but in
a very and i think and i think maybe
some of the it's can speak to this
uh is is in a very good way right
and then how does that balance out uh
with having a hierarchy so we're built
so structured as a guild um
where there's a apprentices uh
journeymen
uh masters grand masters and then
grandmasters with philosophy and science
which is like this
super high level kind of thing but it's
all based on time
so it is very much so a tenured kind of
atmosphere
um when you spend two years as a as a
apprentice you spend another
eight years as a as a journeyman uh ten
years become a master
20 years become a grandmaster 30 years
plus you become grand master of
philosophy and science
um and it's it's it's
that seems very structured and it is
it's not even that it seems right it is
very much so structured
but i think the difference between souls
as an institution and say something like
a mit for example is that you know
solstice end goal
isn't you know just commercialization
it's not to go get a job
you know um it's interesting because the
folks who come in
like already have jobs you know so it's
more like a
a master's program uh in that capacity
uh where you already have a certain
understanding of the craft
this is to open you up to a to a side of
the craft that you would never find so
so to speak in the wild so there is
hierarchy but the the goal of the
institution as a whole
isn't for you to take your your your
master i.t
status and sosa and go and get you know
a job you know or to use it as this or
uses that
it's more internal um facing uh
to give the the it's their insult
something to work towards um and then
the interesting part is you know for
certain institutions
you know the the the the
the label is already defined right it's
defined for you
whereas in salsa because it's so new
source has been around for maybe about
six or seven years now um
you know the the members they define
what that what that means you know what
does it mean to be
uh a journeyman what does it mean to be
a master what does it mean to be a
grandmaster
and there's a certain fluidity in that
and a certain allowance for certain
things so you may think like oh you know
if you get a phd you got to have a
dissertation and a workload and you got
to have a repeat repeat repeating this
as a constant layering
whereas you know you might have a
conversation
also where it's like you know to be a
master is you know can you do one thing
you know and is that one thing that you
do um
solid enough useful enough beautiful
enough
to withstand the test the
time right and that ability to create
that dealer thing
uh qualifies you for that kind of status
but
it's very much so a collective even in a
sense of a lot of that is distributed a
lot of that
what do you want the organization to be
to look like to feel like
is distributed to its members because at
the end of the day that's what social is
so when you mention this at a distance
we're kind of like optimal for this
environment right because a lot of what
souls does
is at a distance um in various formats
um but that that that idea of
you know salsa is the people you know it
is the members it is the ideas it's the
concepts
um versus a building or versus some
platform that is built off of
and can you tell us some of that you
mentioned the solid the useful the
beautiful can you tell us about fuv
about
fermi tasks these uh
ideas of uh what the foundation is of
what we do in so-so
absolutely so um again salsa just to to
reinforce
uh salsa is society's spoken heart it's
it's meant to be it's not meant to be a
place to teach you how to rap
right it's not a place that's meant to
um create
commercial opportunities for you as a
rapper to go through that right we're
not like an agency or anything like that
um because all of that stuff already
exists you know um we're not
we're not a record label all that are
exist what
what didn't exist was an academic
institution
they is solely a sole focus on on rap
um as an art form but also as a science
and
because of that because it's so new you
have this freedom to kind of create a
structure
like to create from scratch and so we
looked at
um you know pre-existing uh
kind of ideas and concepts uh again a
guild
for for example but then what kind of
guild and so we're
looking at the world of architecture and
we looked at architecture because
we def at so-so we define wraps as a
it's an acronym for uh uh rhetorical
anthropological philosophical structures
right that's how we look at raps that's
what a rap is to us
and that structural aspect is very
important
and it immediately lends us to some of
the foundational principles of like
classical
architecture which is this idea of a
form follows function right and foreign
follows function is a
louis sullivan uh but he he pulls that
from even more classic
literal classic greek kind of aspects of
uh
uh uh roman aspects it'd be fermi tosh
utilitas venustas this idea of
things have if you build a building a
structure it has to be solid
um it has to be useful it has to have a
utility um but it also has to be
beautiful
you know and if you're operating under
those three um
constantly using those as reference
reference points at least as macros
um what you'll wind up with is the
optimal
structure you know for whatever you want
to do it for so we we pull that in to
sols this idea of f.u.v
uh fermi tosh utility mustache solidity
usefulness
and uh and beauty um elegance is another
another way to kind of think about that
and apply that to rap you know and so
are the the
the the raps these rhetorical
anthropological philosophical structures
that you're crafting
uh do they possess and operate amongst
all these three
principles at the very least right so
you there can be more
or you can add on more an event more you
can
you know cross an idea but at the very
least does it represent these three kind
of ideals
and realities too yeah so
um so let's talk about i i i you know i
think the architectural
connection and those principles in
particular sort of keeping in mind that
questioning yourself as to are you doing
something that fulfills those three
um is something that brings people
together
over a distance along with their
dedication
to put in the work to study together
and their background their love of
hip-hop their
their expertise uh for the most part
they're no one exception but uh expert
uh rappers
that they are and um
uh those self-deprecation their doctor
stop it
but but i i want to i do want to ask
because
the uh diversity of
people in sosa trying to come together
and study
uh what's very difficult material like
things that you would uh really
be talking about you know in a graduate
curriculum
right but you have people who have phds
you have people who
are 12 years old yeah yeah right yeah
we do we're not
not not 12 anymore yeah but who started
off that way
they started out that way that's part of
sosa right surely surely
yeah um i think i think we look at you
know
salsa from its inception sosa was meant
to be very difficult
right it was meant to start at the top
right and the the first iterations were
attracting the best rappers in the world
you know unapologetically like sosa's
core founding members
are the best rappers in the world right
um
and then working down you know and then
what so now if we're starting there
then okay we don't want to go down we
want to keep going up so
okay now our curriculum that we want to
engage with
has to be the top of the pops you know
it has to be work from
dr nick mumford you know if we're going
to talk about computation and
computational studies
we're going to go to mit right and we're
going to find
or or create associations with um
you know these people who are the
experts in their field um but that isn't
to the point where it's you know
computer jargon and no one can
understand it except
it has to kind of because we're not
geniuses in that space you know we're
geniuses
as rappers right but you know stepping
out of that we
got to take some baby steps but we still
you know uh
challenged ourselves to create a
curriculum and and tie into folks and
individuals
and other institutions uh that were
operating at the highest level you know
so when we talk about we want to study
semiotics and bring semiotics
the conversation of rap and rappers um
we know we go to the semiotics lab at
university of pennsylvania you know talk
to doctor ossie parker and like hey
there's 12 rappers in this room tell us
about semiotics and he hands us a book
this thick
you know it's kind of like well you know
maybe maybe it's a little much but we
appreciate it not
um and then and get engaging folks like
yourself engaging folks like dr foxreal
but also engaging folks like uh uh we
call it uh uh the hip-hop mom
uh chef ir uh for folks that don't know
uh
ir if we throw that around there's a
there's some jargon in salsa ir stands
for in residence
um and actually doc i t we you know i
can't tell you what i t means
but uh ir means in residence and doc i.t
here
is one of started out as one of our
academics in residence this process of
finding the best
in their fields that were willing to
kind of communicate and reciprocate back
into our kind of
into our world so we always looked at
salsa as being like
the mit of rap or the navy seals of rap
right but then to turn that phrase
you know to to have something to work
towards it becomes
how can we establish that the navy seals
you know looks at themselves as the rap
of the military you know or the salsa of
the military type situation you know
um so it is about borrowing but it also
is about like
challenging and adding on um the
experiences and the knowledge that we've
kind of cultivated
in our own space and and you said the
diversity of it ranges from the young
the old
uh the the really really good
the the really really good you know as
we
operate in that space and uh you know
people from all walks of life and all
disciplines and all skill
levels um
and again it's more about you know we
said we say a social that you know
disrespect and sosa is not doing the
work you know so you can be a jerk
you know you can be the the bohemian you
know meditative
nobody talk to me until you know but as
long as you're doing that work
you know as long as you're turning in
those assignments and doing those other
stuff you know
you're fully invested and so there's a
lot
of uh engagement with you mentioned
semiotics but also uh linguistics
conceptual metaphor theory um
computation programming um
the in uh the history of uh rap and
hip-hop
which uh is even among uh people who are
uh very good rappers these days is often
overlooked people don't go back to the
70s a lot of times
to um to really dig into that right um
so one of the things i find uh
interesting though about sosa is that
that is always brought back
into connection with one's own work and
with particular
verses that you find very good so um so
it's not just a
abstract discussion right but you're
trying to figure out for instance
what does conceptual metaphor theory
have to tell you about the way you
write versus as a rapper
um it's a it's a it's a practice based
type of
type of activity ultimately uh even uh
as your your wanderings into um what
what may seem like very esoteric fields
trying to understand
um like uh uh
fox horrell's idea of um phantasms
and the way that that type of
imagination you know uh culturally
connects
um with what people can do in rap
um making those connections back to
one's own work seems to be an important
part
of what people are doing and so
absolutely it's to it's to look at
and we're you know for to give people
some uh
framework so it's not all over the place
um what we're specifically talking about
now is social's apprentice program
um which is a two-year program um that
no matter where you are in rap no matter
how many records you sold
if you're coming into salsa and you want
to do it the long way you're you're in
the trenches for two years
um and so there's this this uh
this program that we do where we it's
the history of rap
basically you know we have uh uh kevin
beecham ir who's like
the einstein of of rap versus you know
um
in terms of just his ability to to
understand them theorize against them
but then has a history of them so he
wrote in the cycle he's running
encyclopedia
um of every rap verse ever written you
know and it's from 1979 to 1989
so we had the pleasure of being able to
pull him in um to create a curriculum
for us
um in terms of rap history and even for
me it was like things that i never heard
right as a guy who's like hey can you
build this for us and uh
and going through the practice of you
know
going back to how we all started you
know looking at someone else's work
breaking it down trying to become that
work um
and then pull out aspects of that work
and add it to our own toolbox
but then also find places in the work
where there's opportunity for innovation
for innovation
right to to impinge oneself and into the
work itself
but in that process you're reinforcing
the um the history
right reinforcing um the origin points
of our craft which is super important so
sosa kind of
spans an entire spectrum of finding our
history
um as rappers in every possible nook and
cranny that
it happens to exist and then also seeing
jumping all the way to the other side of
the spectrum and seeing
you know what is our relationship to
computation you know what is it what is
our relationship to machine learning you
know what is our relationship to ar
um as rappers and what does that look
like you know what is the contemporary
circumstances
which as just as much we might not have
heard any of those verses from 81
we might not be hearing if any of this
work that's being done in labs
at mit for example so a lot of the
process was
finding out the history not only of rap
but then also finding out the history
of all these other fields right so we
can make sure that we're
we're caught up to a certain degree um
so that we do decide to sit down and
create work
and make that decision that we're
operating off all of these kind of
awarenesses
these situational awarenesses of what's
what what's what's been done before what
hasn't been done
before um so you can have more informed
decisions
um and again that's not for the sake of
going out to create a better
commercially successful album right at
the end of the day
it can clearly just be for your own
personal
um working within the craft and
fortunately sosa was able to cr in that
process
able to create a space i would call it a
safe space
because we still call people whack that
salsa
but it has a very specific definition
it's very specific acronym
it's a safer space while we use it
but it is it is a space where you can
just exist and present work in a fashion
that's not
you know critiqued for its lack of
commercial ability or lack of this a
lack of that
and and given his flowers and
understanding in this very specific
context
um of why you're doing this work and it
doesn't have to be like the best ill
super flips of metaphors and double
triple entendres
it could just be executing on a very
simple constraint and
finding space for other folks who know
what you're doing
having to wear that same awareness that
you have and find that kind of
profoundness
in a very simple and i think when folks
understand that and i tease
when they go back to the older work the
classic work
right they come with it with that
understanding of oh now i can see why
this was not only just
culturally significant but
intellectually significant
right so there's that aspect of it as
well
yeah no i mean i think there's a lot to
say about
sort of about studying uh people can be
very dismissive
of early rap and that or well what we're
doing now is so much more advanced
it doesn't have any relationship to that
or there's the other thing is you know
that the idea that's like i don't want
to be a biter
i don't want to you know you know focus
on other people's stuff i just want to
do my own thing
which which a lot of people in creative
writing are like people will be like
oh yeah i don't read my contemporaries
i'm not interested in that i only
you know i only read the past um so
trying to navigate all that and figure
out like how you
uh engage with the culture in not just
not just knowing the stuff or hearing
the stuff or you know having
uh taste you know liking certain things
but
but
actually getting into it and studying it
like uh
being being able to say like yeah you
know this is a rapper who
um not it's not just uh a rapper i like
but i'm gonna study
um you know this this particular work
like that's going to that's going to
fold into my own
my own stuff um
do you want to say any any stuff about
sosa beyond the
uh apprentice program because we're
talking about that as a learning sort of
context because i think it's important
to
uh i think it's important what we do at
mit
i mean we didn't know we'd be in this
distance learning pandemic situation
um when we first talked about your
coming and
uh so i think it's important no matter
what but
uh the idea of how we learn when we're
uh
distributed different places you know is
even more urgent
now but that's also not the only thing
that sosa
does and so if you want to say some more
about uh what sosa is what it does where
it's headed
i want to give you the chance yeah
absolutely i mean
it's about creating a space you know
for rappers to be confident and
comfortable and univer universal
in their space right meaning that your
space has now become
uh a mirror of the entire world because
you deal
specifically with language and language
is the university
universal time factor that ties
everything together and that you possess
a certain mastery
of language right and and compressing
data and
and and being able to uh uh uh
understand and identify nuance
and you can hear a song five or six
different ways so now when you're
hearing
now that you've been trained to
understand what conceptual metaphor is
how
deep it is in our basic communications
you can start to do these kind of
real-time etymological breakdowns right
of like hearing something and you can
hear it
five different ways right and break down
certain
aspects of it that may be going over
people's heads um or really getting to
the core of what people are expressing
right
so there's how do you where can you
apply that right so now
rapper you're a rapper but now you can
seriously become a therapist
right you can seriously be apply
yourself to a different dimension or a
different field and have effective
impact
without changing the way that you think
because the way you think is beautiful
right the way you think is useful the
way you think is solid
um if you can find a way to unite all
that stuff and apply things you can
actually go out and make the world a
better place
in a very intentional way right um
and be be aware of your impacts and be
aware of where you're where you're kind
of slacking off
so there's that kind of like more total
more
maybe aspirational aspect of salsa but
then down to like
the nuts and bolts you know it's about
you know going out
and paying homage and finding and doing
the conservancy and the archival aspects
of
our forefathers and foremothers you know
in this space
and giving it you know
wildest dreams type situation is uh
going back to that collective bargaining
aspect you know
um but doing it in a way where we're not
trying to be adversarial
to the industry but provide services you
know
for our ogs you know to provide places
for them to come
and take care of certain ideas and
initiatives and and just be this
this uh this bridge between worlds right
the new generation and the old
generation
right and show and present that and
create this kind of reciprocity
um past present and future
absolutely and then there's there's you
know have fun
at this you know what does it look like
to have a rap sporting event you know of
which you are
the world champion right now well
what does it look like to take rap and
all these other spaces you know as this
what does it look like as a sporting
event
you know what does it look like as a
game what does it look like
and and bring to it certain certain uh
uh
intentionalities and uh certain
merits um that may or may not work
you know like a space again to kind of
have fun with all the aspects
of our craft
so i i want to leave some time for for
the other people on this call we got
dozens of people who i know
have their questions for you but just
because you're in space
and also because sosa is uh
so this is a north american organization
we should say yes
but i want to ask also about your
perspective on
uh rap and hip hop as a global
phenomenon because
for instance you know professor ian
condrey uh has
uh done the major work on japanese
hip-hop
um uh uh professor uh
jima does you know multilingual uh sound
projects
um and we're very aware that you know
what began
uh uh in the in the bronx um
is you know radically wildly distributed
uh throughout the world these days what
what does that mean in this in this
current context
um i mean sosa is international we got a
it or two
stationed in the uk um one one of the uh
one of the issues and again it's it's
you know separating the apprentice
program from the from the entirety of
social
where it was like you know just time
constraints you know part of the
distributed distance learning is like
you know can you carry a conversation uh
or hold up hold a course uh with
somebody in singapore or while you're
over here and they're over there and
over there
and then language barriers tell me we're
all about that because
we have those issues right now which i
actually actually
literally literally have done uh and
and from hong kong and different places
chiming in to to run up run up run a
room or something but the
the you know there's there has been work
done
to internationalize salsa and in the uh
but some of the barriers are the
language barriers
so part of part of the work over the
last few years
have been like identifying like you know
coalitions of the willing
uh completely in a different language um
to do the same work we did here you know
to find
you know to to immerse yourself in the
linguistics of your language right of
your native language
um and all of the issu all of the little
nooks and crannies and things like that
and then you know partner with the
institutions that exist um that promote
that or conserve that type of
thing and then find the identified
members in your in your rap community
uh that you think would want to be a
part of something like so-so
and so we've been kind of like
identifying different folks um bringing
them to
up to speed on what social is and not
trying to anglicize it you know not
trying to
americanize it like you know here's the
here's the the the international
um guild um but yes if it's completely
in tagalog then so be it you know if
it's completely
in mandarin then so be it um and maybe
we can meet up in the middle somewhere
and trade notes
and do some translation uh but that is
one of the the goals
uh for salsa to be even more
international than it is right now yeah
um um especially coming off of the
constraints of distance learning and
your apprentice program and stuff like
that so
yeah i mean but the organization doesn't
have to be the you in
to be successful right you know there's
the people
in a way also you look at it as the
success of hip-hop
and the way it has energized you know
across
international boundaries um break
dancing
as an olympic event right coming in
congratulations breakdown rap will be
next rap
so all right let me see uh if people
want to
people can ask uh questions using their
own voice
you can have your camera on or not
people can put some questions into the
chat
i want to uh let some of our many
participants
have a chance to speak with you also
lupe hmm
for sure
all right um inna has
a question uh thanks uh nick thanks lupe
i mean i'm a big fan i heard gold watch
in 2007 and my life was transformed i
had to go look up all those things
google and uh deputy candles
but thank you uh you truly are an
inspiration um
you know i've been enlightened today uh
to hear um
about uh sosa in academia there's a
tension
of you know pursuing like research for
the sake of it
or going out to do stuff um with the
knowledge and skills you have
or being commercial which we know um rap
can be
do you envision that happening you know
where there's this fluidity people come
into sosa and go out to create albums
and come back
or you know where do you see how do you
see that tension
kind of working out i mean we we've
you know we're trusted organization so
we're very much so under the cone of
silence
but i mean we've had that you know we've
had uh
uh it's and sosa learn
lessons in salsa and then it's like it's
now it's a song right and it's like
great you know um and then the other
side where there's things that
that are in social that are so um
just complex right it requires such an
amount
of of understanding the history of how
you got to that work
then nobody outside of social would care
about it you know so there's that kind
of aspect some of the research and the
work that's being done
and salsa isn't fit to for public
consumption right
um but i think that's you know we're
very
open about you know what the goal of
sosa is you know which is to create
a space for rappers of all walks of life
whether you're super commercial rapper
or
whatever your piece may be um to have a
place to call home
you know in 100 years in a thousand
years you know and here's a place where
you can come and there's no commercial
pressure to perform
there's no um creative pressure to
perform
but there is an academic pressure to
perform right it's not to have no
pressure
um but a different kind of pressure you
know that we feel will
you know you'll def you we we we say we
we say this but we know this we say that
you know social
not about making you a better rapper but
we know social is going to make you a
better rap
you know and everybody who's come to
salsa uh uh and i'd say to come out the
other side because you never you can
never leave so-so but
within sosa you people become better
rappers they become
you take amazing rappers they become
insanely amazing rappers you know just
from
uh the pressure cooker of the
environment uh the constraints that
you're supplied with
and the kind of the demands you know
that are put upon you as a member of
salsa so
you know if you want to take and i'm
sure and it's all welcome
uh you know it's that take this and make
that amazing album
out of it that would have that without
salsa it might have been
a really good album but now you've kind
of understood your space
a little bit better you understand the
entirety of rap a little better
you know what you're really really good
at right um and then you say you know
what
i would if i wasn't in salsa and this is
me speaking for myself right
if i wasn't in salsa i would have never
made that you know because i would have
been trying to
follow a commercial you know route or
i've been trying to follow a creative
route
but since i'm in salsa i'm gonna take an
academic chance you know i'm gonna
implement something highly conceptual
into this work
and you know let's go and you may not
sell a billion records but you might
make one of the greatest
rap albums of all time you know
so sami has a question and then kasamir
yes uh hi lipa thank you very much for
taking the time um
so my question was sort of it seems to
be
um like sosa kind of deals with
kind of what a lot of people would
consider like good rap quote-unquote
which is like
the pure lyricism of it and like how you
put the words together
i was wondering how you personally and
like social institution
kind of reconciles that with the new
subgenres of hip-hop
that come out that have less
um weight to the actual lyrics and more
of how they sound
uh within songs and also how is that
like
how do you teach something like that
considering it's more abstract
um i mean one of the things in salsa is
is
is salsa is about rap uh
but it's not about rap what do you mean
uh source is about the rappers it's not
about what they rap about
so you can rap about whatever you want
it could be as deep or as high as you
want
what sosa demands is that what once you
wrap it that you're able to write an
essay about
what's in it right and not what's in it
from a conceptual point of view
but from the actual figures of speech
you know can you label and flag all the
figures of speech
can you label all the rhetorical
operations that you just performed or
didn't perform
uh can you do can you where are the
feminine rhymes or the masculine rods
um what is the core metaphor that you
are operating off of
and then also pop quiz you know what are
the
what is the structure of the metaphor
and how does it interact with your
angular gyrus you know uh to to your
to the to the structures of your brain
like where is this stuff coming from so
it's a completely different
conversation that starts to happen right
and that's why i say you
you can hear a song um five different
ways
you know you can hear it as just a
cultural expression of the times
um salsa or salsa i.t we hear it as like
that's about 18 slat rhymes and then
there's i see the the core metaphor
is that i see what kind of you know
like historical concept construct that
he's kind of pushing
there's a certain yeah there's other
aspects that kind of come to life
which which kind of you know belittle
or you know overshadow um do i like this
you know is this you know of a standard
set up by some arbitrary
you know magazine or some message board
so it's a little bit deeper than that
so yes sosa is about rap
but not no not rap as you know
go by my check out my mixtape uh rap as
you know this is a rhetorical
anthropological philosophical structure
and here's why and how right um
more more of a science than of an art so
to speak
hope that answers your question
appreciate the question as well brother
that was great thank you very much
there's a question from casimir and i
think we'll have
time for one more if somebody has
another
um so yeah how's it going um
i've been a huge fan since you know
since middle school
and i wanted to talk a little bit more
about like you personally if that would
be okay um sure
sure so um
i wanted to know i've like heard stories
about
peop from people like close to you
online about you like walking through
your high school like just freestyling
everybody was following you around stuff
and
um i wanted to
sort of know about sort of what was your
creative and artistic process to make
such a great work like food and liquor
and how has that process evolved um
as well as like how much sort of
technical thought do you like sort of
put into these verses or is it some sort
of like you just naturally put out
something and then
after the fact you come back and you're
like oh there's like an extended
metaphor
triple entendre here something like that
um i mean to answer the first question
last and i'll go back to it
right now i don't right now i've gone
through so many different processes
that i don't necessarily have to just
intentionally do one or two like it just
happens now
like at this point the way i've been
doing rap and
investigating it and understanding it um
it just happens
you know um and you know going through
solstice i understand why
that happens right not to keep beating
you overhead with social social salsa
but there is something to understanding
like what that is
like oh i don't even need to like try
this is just what i do
if i put myself in a proper context then
this will come out do i still require
certain inputs absolutely like do i need
to listen to some jay-z
right to really get the the thing going
yes you know so i'll listen to hobie
baby
and like okay i don't want to rap today
i need to rap today
i'm listening to some hobie baby and
then i'm rapping right it sets things
off
so it's important to surround yourself
with inspirations right and it's
be very intentional in the types of
inspirations that you're trying to you
know that you want to
to that's relative to your end result
right
um the mythology of the young lupe
fiasco is
it is a lot of mythology but it is true
though at the same time too there is a
um those people who were following me
around was my old rap crew
right so it was like my homies who also
rap let's all go through the hallways
and rap
together right we would go home and the
same way we had homework for whatever
class
we also had homework to do a verse to
come back to school the next day with a
new verse and that was kind of thing can
you create a whole new verse
you know coming back you know once you
go home and come back to school
um and so i mean
part of that to to bring it a little bit
back into the solstice and take it back
out
is like it's all of those
processes and things that were happening
and things that we were doing
trying to learn how to become rappers
what happens if you formalize that
right what if you can put that into a
certain box right at least from the
performative standpoint
to make it uh not necessarily simple
because it's definitely not simple
but you know compartmentalize it in a
very precise place so it's not all it's
like
feel you know what i'm saying like i
feel this why i think that this is that
is something to have a certain level of
comfort when you know
like if i do xyz this is gonna happen
right
and then you ain't gotta worry about it
you can just automate and you keep it
moving
so um i had my first record deal
i think i was looking at my first record
deal when i was still in high school
so it was a different kind of thing it
was like yeah i'm freestyling and
freestyling but i got this record deal
you know what i'm saying so it was like
all of like rap being a good rapper but
then also like i got this deal
you know what i'm saying oh i got this
on on the verge too
so i really feel like that my upbringing
wasn't as pure
as it may seem because even as i was
learning how to rap
i had commercial opportunities you know
and it's a difference when you just like
all you're doing is learning how to rap
right and then you're like okay now what
now that i'm done
let me go get these commercial
opportunities so i learned a lot of what
i know
um on the road you know i learned a lot
of what i do
you know in the studio versus kind of
like
in the site for
you know or at the open mic you know it
was like
my test run you know is you know my test
drive
is the race you know what i'm saying
so but yeah i hope that answers your
questions brother i apologize if it was
a
little too redundant no no no that was
perfect
thank you yep
all right so we got a question from obie
um yeah can you hear me
all right yeah perfect thank you for
your time um
yeah hey what's up yeah hi thank you um
so just thank you so much and um i love
this idea of sosa
primarily i love how you're bringing
academia to creativity
um and something that kind of came to
mind
is how there is sort of overlap here um
and i was wondering how you've tried to
encapsulate the voices of people that
are underrepresented
excuse me underrepresented um not only
in rap but in academia particularly
women
um so have you tried to target that
issue
in your own um establishment
i mean it's a lot of rap is
is men you know um
but the the kicker is that the
the fundamental core aspects of rap
some of so this the term conscious
rapper
right even that term going all the way
back to 1979.
it wasn't a guy right it wasn't
grandmaster flash and furious 5. they
went first
right it wasn't broken it wasn't it was
a 15 year old
there's the age piece for you right a 15
year old
uh female m.c
by the name of a sweet tea right i.t
um who a lot of people don't know
right even female rappers even male
rappers
right even just in general that this
this young woman
was the first person on wax
um and a release record to talk about
the prison industrial complex in a very
direct way right not kind of beating
around the bush or creating a metaphor
for it but in a very direct way talking
about the police
right um bringing light to the
injustices in the neighborhood right
um but then also just conceptually
killing you with bars and metaphors and
stuff like that same time too but when
it got to the content of it
um you know it becomes like whoa
you know the there this isn't a
grandfather
you know how to talk about grandfathers
or like uh the the
the conscious rap has a grandmother
not a grandfather right that birth that
kind of concept and that idea and even
the way that we practice
conscious rap today and the way we talk
about subjects today
started with this 15 year old girl right
sweet tea i t
um and so in salsa there is this kind of
like
you look at certain pieces of the
curriculum you look at uh
but but but it's different because to be
fair so one of the books that we study
uh outside of rap is called a jokes in a
linguistic mind
uh which is written by this female
professor you know who just so happens
to have a
depth of knowledge and jokes and
cognition and things like that we study
her
deeply right she's one of the core kind
of uh
manuals that we that we rip off of and
use as a god
um the that that 12 year old that
that doc i.t mentioned earlier in the
talk you know is this
young 12 year old girl you know who's
one of the best rappers in the world
you know um and it's it's kind of like
we're we're at the mercy of everyone
else you know breaking through these
kind of patriarchal
pieces but i think the the great thing
about salsa
versus any other kind of group that's
dealing with this is that we're new
so we don't have any excuses right so we
can come in with intention
to bring aboard as many um participatory
academics that are female uh sosa it's
that are female our mother hen at sosa
is a mother hen nikki j niti is like the
the
the mom of sosa uh keeps everything
running and on point
and hopefully over the next uh a few
years as we build out social and grow it
and do different things
there's more of an intentionality to
bring in
more female emcees but also more female
academics to come in and participate but
i think
i think that we've done somewhat of a
good job we'll probably get a b minus
i'll give us a b minus
for that but i mean unfortunately in rap
when you look out there it is a
it is a dearth of that especially when
we first started but now
different there's a lot more female
representation and so hopefully uh
sosa's books will reflect that
in the future awesome thank you
appreciate you
so we have our closed captioning for
another few minutes
and there's another question from
kasamir um if
anybody else does want to ask something
of lupe please raise your hand
we'll go for as long as we have time
cool and just a yeah in the meantime
somebody pops in or not
um just to kind of like reestablish
um some of my goals uh
here at uh in this residency um
is to you know introduce folks to sosa
introduce the kind of the point of view
that i take when looking at rap
um and very interested to kind of like
participate in the various capacities
um in various groups over at mit
not only personally from our own
creative selfishness
but also to understand um which was one
of the points of doing this residency
was to understand how a institution
works
you know to kind of go into an
institution see it's
similar to the question that the young
lady just asked um
you know lack of representation in one
kind of demographic
how can sosa learn from that um so we
don't make that same
um have that same kind of critique level
against us
what are some other just administrative
aspects and then what is the freedoms of
creativity that are there as well so
um there is a a learning arc
for me in this residency um and outside
of me just being a rapper
but treating salsa as a wrap and seeing
how i can build
and help create the best
verse possible to meet our goals
in addition to me just wanting to you
know
battle wrap a computer you know and
visit the nuclear reactor
so i can say that i did it you know
yeah i keep wanting to stop by and see
if my id works
on that door um probably not
not these days uh and it doesn't it
doesn't work anywhere on campus
uh casimir had a question
another one uh yeah
um i i don't know i'm sorry if i'm like
taking
so much time man nah rock out is fine
um but yeah so i mean something who
something that you were saying to that's
my friend abby
um in terms of like socially conscious
rap
and things like that um there's a line
from like
a jay-z song i'm sure you know it's a
moment of clarity
um where he's talking about like he
he went platinum and he hasn't been
wrapped like common sense
and um i've always been kind of curious
like
you have the skill like undeniably
to have been like a jay-z level
or a drake level rapper um
what is it that sort of like
caused you or sort of motivated you to
shift in a more like socially conscious
and arguably less popular direction
um and are you sort of like spreading
that socially conscious
culture through sosa
um for me it was a decision to either
put out
kick push or put out this song about the
streets
and that literally happened was this
crossroad of like okay
you're you're really gonna put out your
first record your relief really finna
take this road right and
like my friends were in prison you know
and it was kind of like
coming out of a circumstance of the hood
and it's like here's your crossroads
moment where you can either
continue to add to that or you can
challenge it
right create another path the one path
is laden with gold and riches
right um the other path is laden with a
little bit of gold
you know but a lot of controversy a lot
of other things right
and it was like to make the the total
choice for
everyone you know and i felt the best
thing that i could do was to give you
kick push
right the best thing selfishly for
myself but also to give to the world
you know a little bit of redemption song
as they say
um and you know
as that relates to salsa i don't know
social is not like my own it's not
social's not like my personality you
know it's not like a personal culture or
something like that
you know it is very democratic very
distributed um
but there is this kind of like idea that
we're trying to implement
into salsa uh again it's fuv
you know is it solid is it useful is it
beautiful you know is what you're doing
based on fundamental sound principles
that are repeatable that withstand the
test of time
right um or is it just whimsy and for
the sake of
the now right here today gone tomorrow
um
can people actually use this right is it
something that they can actually
um add value to their lives then
you know lastly uh is it is it something
that's really good to hear
something that's really good to look at
or you just giving people
uh more of the noise more of the same
more of the same
i think one of the differences between
myself and others
outside of that choice and same thing
for you or any other rapper on this call
is uh you know tone you know which is
something that you'll discover once you
get through
content you get through context you get
through all these different you get
through the fundamentals
it comes down to how your voice sounds
on music
you know and uh folks like drake folks
like jay-z
otlt they're very much so
masters in their own right but they also
have the tone of the moment
you know they have a certain uh you know
my voice can sometimes come across as
you know nasally and maybe not the best
voice you want to dance to
right um but there's just a little bit
of that as well
like what the decision to you know deal
with the things that you're born with
you know and make the best out of those
and just respect and accept those things
that come along with that
but also the intentionality of the the
cultural choices that you choose to make
and understanding the constraints and
limitations that are that come along
with that as well
you know so i think that i feel like i
i feel like if i went down that route i
i would have never made what i feel is
what
my legacy what i wanted to be which is
you know sosa i wouldn't have made i
wouldn't have made that because i'd have
been way too rich
had way too many chains uh to to care
maybe i'm i'm joking but i hope that
answers your question brother
yeah uh yeah definitely um perfect again
thank you
appreciate you so let me check
while we're all here if there is another
question we got captioning for another
few minutes
so we can take one more if anybody wants
to put a hand
uh whether you're mit or i.t
tesla um
hi uh i am a
huge hip-hop fan and you are one of my
favorite artists
um and uh i had a question about
how uh like a big thing that factors
into my life and my relationship with
with hip hop
is uh as a white person trying to engage
with it in a way that is appreciative
and collaborative and not
appropriative and i was wondering uh how
sosa
thinks about this educating about this
and also
have the ability to control who
membership is
of of who comes in or out how how you
engage with ideas of of who is
in or out and uh like talking about
these sensitive issues
oh man first first of all tesla amazing
question and thank you for it but i have
a question for you are you
on a boat right now
yes uh i study ocean robotics
and i'm living on a boat right now
i love it i absolutely love it um
i mean doc i.t um is it is it possible
to throw that question back to you
um i mean i can i can speak to it but i
think you embody
um everything that she just kind of
asked
you know well or i can't feel it as well
right
so i mean we we one of the things that i
guess i brought up
at the end of our conversation earlier
it's the idea that you know hip-hop
originates um because of
african-americans and the bronx in
harlem beginning this new type of
practice
um involving uh rap um
involving djing uh
graffiti art break dancing is all part
of that
um uh bringing the knowledge of a
community
together in with that um at the same
time
it's a global uh phenomenon it's a
global practice and it's not just uh
something that uh purely imitates like
the american perspective
i mean i one of my friends i was trying
to explain you know hip-hop is really
global
to uh to somebody's nobody you know
there's nobody like doing hip-hop in
greenland
you know i was like oh let's go on
youtube you know we find out yeah here's
somebody here's a native person in
greenland
you know rapping in his native language
and it's not about you know uh
it's not an imitation of something that
goes on in the us it's about the
problems of that society and his
perspective right
um so you know
uh my sense is that
um uh we want to be respectful this is
one of the reasons to study
um what the history of hip-hop is we
need to be respectful of its origins
just as we always would
we need to acknowledge who who the
ancestors of the past
are um and
we also need to consider that um there
is
hip-hop in japan there is hip-hop and
francis hip-hop in greenland
i bring up uh uh doc i.t because he is
one of those
you know uh uh uh
white rappers you know he is
is is damn good at it um
and went through the process of of
really embedding
um himself in the in the culture that is
wrapped in hip-hop
um outside of any other kind of
constraints or limitations
um but you know to directly get to your
your
your question i mean we get salsa is a
rainbow you know it's a rainbow of
individuals and folks
from every religion to every you know uh
color and demographic and even age group
in certain degrees and
you know uh job skill level and you know
all that
all of that is kind of represented fully
in salsa
and it's something to not get caught up
in the color
aspects or the demographic aspects but
to get caught up in the work
aspects you know and that's why we kind
of reinforce
uh you know and focused on objectivity
and
academia versus how dope do you think my
song is
because there's no room to deal with uh
does it would it be better if i was
black would it be better if i was
mexican would it be better if i was
japanese
it's like no can you explain what you
just did you know
and let's let that be the first starting
point and we can get into
other nuances later or maybe not because
we'll spend a majority of the time or
maybe hopefully the entirety of our time
talking about what you just did you know
versus
who did it you know and what they're
backing in so
you know to your point you're more than
welcome to apply
no matter what race color creed uh you
come from
um trust me it's not about who you are
it's about what you do
um and that's what's most important
that's also
all right i think we came to a
conclusion
uh lupeity thank you so much for
joining us it's great i think it's
really good to hear about
um the project of sosa in a time
when all of us are learning at a
distance um
it's also good to hear about um the way
you've been pushing through in these
times the way
you've been productive you've been
contributing to
communities um and we're looking forward
to
uh having you at mit uh
fingers crossed you know in person uh
being able to do some collaboration
being able to have some community work
here um
so thanks very much um
we're really glad that uh we were able
to get together in this format
and we'll look forward to the
continuation of your
time as a visiting artist indeed thank
you uh
to the staff again thank you dr t
appreciate you um
thanks to everybody who tuned in and and
shared your time
uh with me to hear me rant about these
little things
uh more to come hopefully get the chance
to make it down on campus and
and and be able to touch and talk and
see and move around and do different
stuff like that
uh really appreciative of the
opportunity we'll be making the best and
the most
out of it and uh you know i hope it adds
value
um to everyone involved so appreciate
you very much so